I'm just not that good with people
there is one thing I'm good at
mission was to find out what they knew
but that's kind of difficult now that
you killed everyone
I just don't think you're cut out for
the intelligence this is your last shot
oh my god you have jelly all over your
face I'm definitely posting that on
insta is it too late to home-school me
are you CIA streaming if Kim finds out
we got made by a nine year old my career
is over what's the option kill her make
it look like an accident
maybe the stairs oh wow still recording
we can cut a deal I want you to teach me
how to be a spy just to be clear this is
a one-time arrangement never again keep
shooting rains obstacle course try to
walk away from the explosion a lie
detector test I can smell a lie
endorphins really Shinoda and the
ultimate tell slightest wink of an eye
like this I admire all of your tattoos
JJ I believe he is that you've never
taken steroids damn she's good when you
look out there what do you see 90
civilians minimal security software
meter smiling people having fun he's
excited sometime
[Music]
Marty
[Applause]
the objective of this exercise was to
get past me a good idea might be to
cause the distraction because otherwise
there'd be zero chance of you
[Music]
what is he doing looks like the wedding
at the end of Shrek
you